when we first came here the fish were so
depleted because the fishing methods
have become more destructive and you
could go along a coral reef for ten
minutes and hardly see a fish as a
marine biologist I quickly realized that
I really wanted to do something that was
going to make a difference we know that
if these areas are properly protected if
they looked after by the community then
we see recovering and protection of the
ocean we're on the denying bank one of
six double barrier reefs in the world
it's globally significant this place
from marine biodiversity point of view
[Applause]
plastic is not meant to be in the ocean
at all and it does no good to anything
plastic has been found in every single
bit of the ocean that people have looked
what we have been working on is how do
we solve marine conservation in poor
fishing communities like we find here in
this part of the Philippines and if
you're worried about where your next
meal is coming from how you're going to
pay for your child to go to school how
you're going to treat a parent who's
sick your needs are absolutely immediate
and that's the balance that we've been
struggling to find many of our team are
also community organizers people who can
talk to people so I couldn't stand here
and talk to the community about science
but without understanding what's going
on for these communities what their
daily concerns and pressures are then we
can't come up with solutions
we knew there were a lot of fishing nets
on the island you can see them lying
around entangled in the mangroves lying
on the beaches more and more nets are
being used as there's less and less fish
and people more and more desperate
they're trying to find those fish and
they need more nets to do so info from
busy young mouth I see em much more
alone so we have within our pocket and
no matter the lungs are additional
income we were able to develop a global
supply chain to collect nets aggregate
nets bail net export nets from the
Philippines to Europe recycle those nets
to nylon yarn that then can be made into
carpet
[Music]
so working with with Matt's networks
regional manager and there's been really
one of the brain Charles so we've worked
together almost 20 years the first
generation of nets that we collected are
very used to be very dirty because
people were collecting nets that had
been on the shoreline for years but here
we are collecting them straight from the
areas where they replace and amend the
nets
this is just a proof that we are
effective because fishers are no longer
throwing their used fishing nets into
the fishing ground just from this one
Island we've had 18 tons of nets and so
we can make a difference there is hope
there is optimism and there are
solutions but we need innovation and
collaboration to do that
what is so inspiring for me is actually
seeing what communities who have so very
little can actually do and how much
change they can make
[Music]
the other represents in science behind
this thing people can easily buy into
something that's supported with strong
science
[Music]
from a small island in the Philippines
were part of a solution that works
economically it works
environmentally it works for the people
who live here all of these things are
making a difference every day to
people's lives
we are very convinced that the tool that
we have developed that we have evolved
is highly applicable to solve other
plastics issues
[Music]
[Music]